amanda vive en fairbanks alaska la
siguiente tabla muestra los cambios de
temperatura en fairbanks durante un
periodo de 2 horas de las 3 pm a las 4
pm la temperatura aumentó 2 grados
celsius y después de las 4 a las 5
la temperatura disminuyó 5 grados
celsius amanda observa que la
temperatura a las 5 pm es de menos 9
grados celsius cuál fue la temperatura
en fairbanks a las 3 pm aquí básicamente
nos dicen la temperatura al final de
estos cambios y quieren que obtengamos
la temperatura al inicio de estos
cambios veamos si podemos hacer eso
déjame dibujar ya que solemos imaginar a
los termómetros en una posición vertical
dibujaré una recta numérica vertical
aquí para pensar un poco en esto así que
aquí vamos
muy bien entonces a las 5 pm tenemos
menos 9 grados celsius solo digamos que
esto es 0 - 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 menos 6
menos 7 de los 8 menos 9
terminamos en menos 9 grados celsius
este de aquí es 0 grados celsius de las
4 pm a las 5 pm la temperatura bajó 5
grados celsius y eso nos lleva a menos 9
bajamos 5 para llegar a menos 9 así que
debimos de haber empezado 5 grados por
arriba de menos 9 12
45 justo aquí esto representa esa caída
esta es la caída de 5 grados 1 2 3 4 5
esto muestra la caída de 5 grados esto
es menos 5 grados celsius entonces a las
4 pm justo a las 4 pm debimos de haber
tenido una temperatura de 5 grados
arriba de menos 9 lo que será menos 4
menos 4 grados celsius esta fue la
temperatura a las 4 pm esto es a las 4 a
las 4 pm y luego para saber la
temperatura a las 3 pm recuerda que de 3
pm a las 4 pm nuestra temperatura
incrementó 2 grados celsius
así que incrementamos 2 grados celsius a
partir de esa hora para llegar a menos 4
grados celsius
así que incrementamos 2 grados celsius
si incrementamos dos grados celsius para
llegar a 4 esto significa que a las 3 pm
debimos haber estado 2 grados abajo de
ese valor así que esto es lo que hicimos
de las tres a las cuatro de las tres a
las cuatro incrementamos dos para llegar
para llegar a menos cuatro esto de aquí
son los más dos grados celsius justo ahí
así que debimos de haber empezado justo
aquí a las tres de l debemos haber
empezado justo ahí a las
pm
lo que hice fue describir esto si
sabemos que acabamos en menos 9 y de las
4 a las 5 bajamos 5 grados eso significa
que a las 4 debimos haber estado 5
grados arriba de menos 9 que es menos 4
y luego si de 3 a 4 incrementamos 2
grados para llegar ahí eso significa que
a las 3 debimos de haber estado dos
grados abajo de menos 4 por lo que esto
de aquí es menos 6 grados celsius así
que cuál fue la temperatura en fairbanks
a las 3 pm era menos 6
grados celsius
y puedes verificar eso si empiezas en
menos seis aumentados llegas a menos
cuatro y luego si le resta cinco llegas
a menos nueve lo que es exactamente el
valor que tenemos aquí